[Musik]
eine reale sommer buch muss ein zum
lachen bringen ich denke das ideale
sommer buch passt in den rucksack und
nimmt es nicht übel wenn ich dort
gequetscht wird oder werden sogar mal
eine wasserflasche ausläuft das heißt
ein ideales sommer buch sollte und treu
begleiten aber anspruchslos sagen
abtauchen in eine andere wirklichkeit
und da man im alltag wenn man sonst eben
nicht urlaub hat so after unterbrochen
wird bedeutet für mich lesen im sommer
sich auch völlig in eine andere fiktion
hineinzubegeben ein ideales sommer buch
sollte das mitbringen was auch ein
ideales winter herbst und frühlings buch
mit bringt es sollte eigentlich in der
hauptsache nur unterhalten mehr verlange
ich erstmal nicht
also im grunde gibt für mich keine
sommer bücher oder winter bücher ich
lese tatsächlich nicht nach jahreszeiten
weil ich beim lesen letztlich teile
eines anderen kosmos werde und dieser
kosmos hat seine ganz eigenen gesetze
und auf seine eigenen temperaturen und
wettervorhersagen aber wenn man jetzt
davon ausgeht dass wir über sommer
bücher sprechen und würde ich immer
sagen ein genre das sich eignet regens
in den sommerferien sind kurzgeschichten
weil die abwechslung da einfach höher
ist dann sind diese kurzen texte
eigentlich wunderbar zu lesen
für mich gibt es zwei arten von idealen
sommer büchern dass eine stellte welchen
die eine andere ist als die die ich
kenne aber bitte eine vollständige welt
mit allen oben unten vorne hinten
das andere ist stilistisch oder der form
nach so interessant dass ich die welt
die ich zwar kenne um die es geht aber
gar nicht mehr wiedererkennen kann oder
sie neu erkennen kann oder neu finde
also entweder da lege ich also oder wow
da kann man auch leben das kann man sich
auch vorstellen
und das tolle ist es gibt ein buch das
kann beides denn das handels war von der
welt nicht die unsere ist und nicht die
meine ist und eigentlich die von
niemandem ist das nicht die welt gar
nicht gibt aber sie verfremdet und das
auf eine weise dass sozusagen die
verfremdung des ohnehin fremden umkippt
vj minus mal minus gleich plus in das
gefühl da war ich schon immer da bin ich
zu hause da wollte ich endlich mal
wieder hin
liebe hörerinnen und hörer ist es im
sommer es sind ferien oder sie stehen
kurz bevor für viele eine der schönsten
gelegenheiten im jahr zum ausgiebigen
lesen
wir haben hier im bücher podcast gemacht
was wir eigentlich schon lange einmal
machen wollten wir haben ein paar
unserer lieblings kolleginnen und
kollegen gefragt was die ideale
sommerlektüre für sie ausmacht und wo
wir schon mal dabei sind ob sie nicht
eine empfehlung für uns hätten
die antworten kommen von julia behr
dietmar dath julia encke sandra kegel
kann spanke und tilman spreckelsen und
im anschluss hören sie noch ein gedicht
aus der frankfurter anthologie einfache
sätze heißt es von helmut heißen würde
ich empfehle für den sommer
julia behr immer mal zu gast hier im
bücher podcast ist redakteurin bei faz
net was empfiehlst du dafür ein buch
selbst im hotel ist kein roman sondern
ein theaterstück von daisy parker
geboren 1893 als rothschild allerdings
sicher zu ihren großen persönlichen
schmerz dem armen flügel der familie und
dorothy parker aber eine sehr produktive
schriftstellerin in ganz
unterschiedlichen bereichen c hat
gedichte geschrieben sie hat
kurzgeschichten geschrieben auch
kritiken für die sie allerdings
irgendwann rausgeflogen weil vanity fair
weil sie den zur ironie schon zu beißen
und war außerdem theaterstücke wie eben
ladies im hotel
worum geht's inlays im hotel geht es wie
der name schon sagt um damen die in
einem hotel leben das hotel ist von
etwas abgekühlten glanz und man könnte
behaupten das ist bei den damen ähnlich
sind wir sind alle schon etwas älter
zwar so ab 50 aufwärts aber damals galt
das nun als alt die meisten verriet wird
eine getrennt lebend und diese damen
sind sehr unterschiedlich also eine
sitzt zum beispiel im rollstuhl und hat
ihren sohn dabei die andere ist er
einsam manche sind sehr reich manche
sind sehr arm eine arbeitet sogar noch
was natürlich für die anderen sehr
exotisch ist
und es lebt eben wie sich das für ein
theaterstück damals auch gehörte von den
dialogen und die dialoge sind sehr schön
witzig weisen treffend das ist also ein
buch was man am besten selbst im hotel
liest ja man kann das ganz hervorragend
über tendenzen und charlie parker hatte
auch sehr viele farben mit leben im
hotel weil sie nämlich nach der
scheidung von ihrem ersten mann eine
weile lang selbst in dem hotel gelebt
hat in dem sie auch einen literarischen
zirkel hatte in diesem buch gibt es
wundervolle dialoge und überhaupt
einfach so tiven zum beispiel sagt du
die eben im alter von fünfzig verwittert
ist und da einzieht
dazu warum sich niemals zurück wird in
ihrer heimatstadt
ich habe alle brücken hinter mir
abgebrochen und die ruinen machen sich
prächtig oder wenn die dann sich
unterhalten da sagt einem was ist
eigentlich mit major bord ist hier ein
bisschen dünner und der andere antwortet
ich denke doch süß seit zwei jahren tot
durch die parker hat übrigens wenn man
diese art von boshaftigkeit schätzt auch
die hate songs geschrieben also hassen
wieder für mezzo sopran und orchester
das kann man sich bei der gelegenheit
auch sehr sehr gut mal anhören
es ist alles nicht fröhlich was sie
geschrieben hat aber es ist sehr dankbar
[Musik]
ich glaube ich würde immer das buch von
turandot anna spiel das erste gewand
mitnehmen dass sein georgischer moderner
klassiker aus mitte der 70er jahre
das ist ein buch das schildert
eigentlich einen ausschnitt aus einem
leben ein junger mann liebt in seinem
dorf vollkommen zufrieden mit sich und
mit dem kauf aber er fühlt eine gewisse
unruhe und dann kommt irgendwann ein
fremder ins darauf und erzählt von der
großen weiten welt da draußen
und dann ist es um diesen jungen mann
geschehen
der bricht auf der kommt in verschiedene
orte verschiedene städte verschiedene
lebensweisen hinein und verwandelt sich
dabei und wie er sich verwandelt und ihr
am ende zurück kommt in das
ursprüngliche dorf das ist sicher
bemerkenswert und sehr ergreifend tilman
spreckelsen es auch ein gern gesehener
und gehörter gast bei unserem bücher
podcast literaturredakteur bei uns im
haus was macht dieses buch zu einem
idealen sommer buch für dich das ist ein
buch das man oft legen kann und das ist
ja bei einem sommer buch immer wenn man
verreist etwa ganz wichtig man hat wenig
platz man kann sich bei den büchern
eigentlich kaum einen fehler erlauben
und das ist so ein buch was ich oft
gelegen habe was ich immer wieder gerne
lesen möchte das ist er weiß ich schon
mal das ist kein fehlgriff ist aber zum
anderen auch ein buch was vollkommen
licht und luft und wärme in sich trägt
auch an ganz finsteren stellen
das heißt es ist ein buch was einem ein
gefühl vermittelt hier geht es ums ganze
geht es ums ganze leben und zugleich ist
diese erzählweise leicht wie eben ein
sommer idealerweise sein kann
wie hast du das buch entdeckt dann hast
du es ein erstes mal gelesen ich habe
entdeckt als georgien gastland der
frankfurter buchmesse war 2008 sehen und
da war das dann eine von sehr vielen
anderen übersetzungen ich habe mich ein
bisschen auf die orgien spezialisiert
habe das hat auch dieses buch gelesen
was einen großen vor schluss
vorschusslorbeeren herausgegeben wurde
auf deutsch erstmals ins deutsche
übersetzt und ich war sofort gefangen
das klingt also nach einem arbeits
kontext und nicht nach einem urlaubs
kontext in dem das kennengelernt hast
hast du es dann noch mal auf eine andere
weise im urlaub gelesen ich habe es
danach mehrfach noch gelesen im urlaub
noch nicht aber es darf momente wo ich
zeit hatte und wo ich das gefühl hatte
ich möchte jetzt sehr sehr gerne dieses
buch noch mal in aller ruhe wieder lesen
und vielleicht was neues dran entdecken
es war richtig einen verlangen nach
diesem buch ist mir eigentlich selten
die hoffentlich mein buch finde es schön
wenn weniger schön und dann ist das auch
abgehakt und mit diesem buch bin ich
einfach nicht fertig geworden
das klingt nach einer sehr starken
empfehlung wo ist es gemeint vielen dank
über thema
also diese idealen sommer bücher bei
denen ich abtauchen kann in eine andere
wirklichkeit sind sehr gerne bücher des
israelischen schriftsteller david
grossman auch letztes jahr im sommer da
war es in griechenland habe ich was nina
wusste gelesen das war sein
sein neues buch das damals neu
erschienen war letztes jahr auf deutsch
aber welches buch also das wirklich für
mich ideale buch ist eine frau flieht
vor einer nachricht das ist schon 2009
10 von david grossmann und dabei ist
tatsächlich ich weiß nicht ob du das
kennst das man liest und immer langsamer
liest weil man nicht möchte dass ein
buch aufhört das ist ein bisschen so als
wenn man in einem kinofilm ist und aus
dem kinofilm herauskommt und noch ein
bisschen sich fühlt als wäre man noch in
der stimmung dieses films oder als würde
man ein teil der wirklichkeit des films
oder der fiktion des films die man dann
als wirklichkeit empfindet mit hinaus
nehmen in das leben vor dem kino so eine
stimmung die man weiter trägt und hier
ist es eigentlich auch so dass ich noch
tagelang nach diesem buch eine frau
flieht vor einer nachricht diese
stimmung dieses buchs in mir
fortgetragen habe hinaus genommen habt
in mein eigenes leben und für mich das
wirklich ein ganz unvergesslich eine
unvergessliche lektüre war julia encke
leitet das feld von der sonntags zeitung
leitete vorher dort die literatur und
war auch schon mal hier zu gast im
bücher podcast ja bitte erzählt uns mehr
über das buch liebe julia über die
atmosphäre die man von dort dann raus
nimmt ja es geht um eine unglaublich
tragische geschichte es geht um eine
frau namens zora was hebräisch licht
bedeutet deren sohn sich freiwillig für
den kriegsdienst in israel verpflichtet
und diese frau hat eine vorahnung dass
er sterben wird also dass irgendwann die
überbringer der nachricht seines todes
kommen werden und um den sohn zu
schützen beschließt sie nicht zu hause
zu sein also sie denkt wenn sie nicht da
ist wird die hiobsbotschaft überhaupt
nie ankommen können und
also weil sie meint eine nachricht gibt
es schließlich nur dann wenn es eine
empfängerin oder einen empfänger gibt
und ora begibt sich also verlässt das
haus und begibt sich auf eine wanderung
durch galiläa die sie eigentlich mit
ihrem sohn hatte machen wollen und zu
der sie jetzt einen freund einlädt mit
ihr zu kommen und diesen freund erzählt
sie während sie zusammen durch das land
israel angehen
von ihrem sohn also sein ganzes leben
bis ins kleinste detail und sie erzählt
diese erzählt von ihrem sohn um ihn auf
diese weise am leben zu halten und das
ist natürlich auch einer der gründe
warum man nicht möchte dass dieses buch
auf wird weil man weiß so lange sie
erzählt wird wird er weiter leben
nämlich in ihrer erzählung und es ist
ganz tragisch und und auch furchtbar
dass grossmann als er angefangen hat das
buch zu schreiben das war im mai 2003
ein halbes jahr zuvor war seine eltern
so hatte sein älterer sohn jonathan
seinen militärdienst beendet und ein
halbes jahr danach wurde sein sohn juri
allen berufen
beide dienten beim israelischen panzer
chor und uri der dann ein anrufen wurde
während david grossman dieses buch
schrieb erkannte auch die handlung des
buches und immer wenn er mit seinem team
hat er telefonierte oder wenn er
zwischendurch mal an einem wochenende
hause kam fragte er immer nach was ist
inzwischen passiert mit der geschichte
eines helden und was hast du uns wieder
angetan weil die söhne natürlich wussten
dass es irgendwie auch um sie geht und
großmann schreibt in den markt nachwort
dieses buches das er damals dieses buch
angefangen zu schreiben weil er das
gefühl hatte dass er seinen sohn uri
schützen müsste dass er hatte natürlich
angst dass etwas passieren könnte und
die frage die sich eben stellt ist kann
ein buch ein leben retten und das
furchtbare ist dass dieses buch
das leben nicht retten konnte das im
august 2006 als am 12 august war das
damals eigentlich in den letzten stunden
des zweiten libanon-kriegs der sohn uri
im südlibanon getötet wurde also nicht
im buch sondern in wirklichkeit
bei dem versuch die besatzung eines
anderen betroffenen panzers zu retten
wurde der panzer von einer rakete
getroffen und neben uri starb auch die
ganze besatzung und dieses wissen weil
es eben auch in dem nachwort reflektiert
wird dieses wissen dass das passiert ist
das also quasi das leben in die
literatur eingebrochen ist und die
literatur sollte eigentlich das leben
retten
dieses wissen macht diese bitte macht
diese verschränkung von von wirklichkeit
und literatur als erlebnis auch in der
lektüre so intensiv dass man es
tatsächlich nicht vergisst und und ich
fand es auch deshalb so ein großartiges
buch weil wenn man verstehen will was
israel ist für ein land also wenn sie
geht ja durch dieses land sie
sie wandert also ist auch eine
geschichte der kriege israels es ist
eine eine geschichte also ganz ganz
verschiedene zeiten auch eine rolle
spielen weil sie alles mögliche
rekapituliert im erzählen dieses lebens
ihres sohns und früher und es gibt eine
szene wo der kleine sohn auf dem applus
zu hause entdeckt wie winzig israel ist
also eigentlich nur eine fingerkuppe
groß und er sagt so das gibt's doch gar
nicht wir sind hier um zingel von
feinden und wir sind so klein und dann
sagt die mutter ja aber hier die das
sind die freunde das sind dann die
vereinigten staaten und dann stellt er
fest ja aber die sind so weit weg kommt
dass man oder sind so viele seiten
dazwischen weil der anlasser immer
weitergeht und amerika einfach viele
seiten weiter ist und was sie wie es
sich anfühlt in israel zum leben und
welche geschichte dieses land hat dafür
entwickelt man in
diesem roman finde ich ein großartiges
gespür und viel besser als in so vielen
sachbüchern oder dokumentation also das
ist deshalb ziemlich sensationelles buch
ich ganz kann ich jedem empfehlen darin
in den feldern abzutauchen
ja klingt für mich nicht gerade so als
würde man es dann kurzschließen und der
blick geht dann so über dem strand oder
eine ferienanlage oder man ließ das
offen auf einer liege oder in
irgendeinem schatten oder bei
irgendeinem trinkt oder so also was ist
mit dem gewicht dieses buch ist ja das
ist sehr sehr wichtig und ich aber das
ist vielleicht eine typen frage es gibt
glaube ich unterschiedliche leserinnen
oder leser in den ferien und ich bin
tatsächlich nicht jemand sie gerne
leichte unterhaltsame bücher liest
anstatt man denn ich möchte wirklich
dann endlich die bücher lesen für dich
zeit habe und die mir viel bedeuten und
und was nicht und unterhaltsame bücher
das fand ich dann immer so langweilig
also ich da gibt es bestimmt andere
typen also andere mögen dann lieber auch
in meiner familie krimis und sind dann
auch sehr schnell und lesen ein krimi
nach dem anderen weg oder auch leichte
bücher aber ich bin nicht der typ ich
mag gerne gewichtige schwere bücher von
denen ich dann eben so an ein
leseerlebnis auch mit nehmer und in den
ferien hat man einfach zeit dafür
deshalb für die schöne gute ferien sind
hast du das buch ein erstes mal in den
ferien gelesen oder wie waren die
umstände unter denen du das buch
entdeckt oder ein erstes mal gelesen
hast also dieses buch habe ich
tatsächlich nicht in den ferien gelesen
aber ich habe es auch draußen in parks
gelesen und bin irgendwo hingegangen wo
ich ihn für mich war tatsächlich habe
ich aber dieses mieten dieses letzte
buch von david kross man das in kroatien
spielt auch eigentlich ein schweres buch
habe ich in vielen gelesen letztes jahr
am strand und
es war nicht ganz so dick wie eine frau
flieht vor einer nachricht wirklich sehr
fast 700 sein ist aber das kenne ich
auch sehr griechenland verlassen damals
das nimmst du diesmal mit weiß ich noch
nicht
also dass sich tatsächlich nicht so
richtig sicher
das muss ich noch entscheiden ein
köstlicher moment man sollte diese
entscheidung nicht voreilig trifft also
um mich herum gegen so jetzt mehrere
stapel von büchern
ich musste es noch aus sehr gut habe
vielen dank ich wie du dir das sommer
buch meiner wahl ist der kosmos
vogelführer von lars svensson ein vogel
bestimmungsbuch dass jeder ornithologe
braucht der loszieht und vögel bestimmen
möchte kein spannendes kollege bei uns
in der sachbuch redaktion vogelfreund
und war schon ein paar mal zu gast hier
in bücher podcast wird erzählt uns mehr
über das buch lieber also der kosmos
vogelführer von von lars svensson ist so
etwas wie ein standardwerk er kam bei
uns zuerst 999 raus hat seitdem einige
überarbeitungen erfahren und ist der mit
abstand beste vogelführer den man in
deutschland kriegen kann nicht nur hier
übrigens auch in großbritannien wird er
benutzt und das aus gutem grund er
arbeitet mit illustrationen nicht mit
fotos und sind alle vögel die man in
deutschland in europa an treffen kann
darin verzeichnet genauso auch die arten
nordafrikas und vorderasiens und auch
ein paar selten leiten die sich die sich
manchmal hierher verirren aber die hier
gar nicht hingehören
das klingt nach einer bibel also noch
ein riesen welt seitdem schlägt man noch
nicht mit sich herum
den gibt's mittlerweile als eben
tatsächlich ich habe ihn auch als app
und wenn man ihn in buchform mit sich
rumschleppt dann sind es tatsächlich so
440 seiten also schon schwer okay wie
benutzt man so etwas also ich denke
meine draußen unterwegs sieht ein vogel
und denkt
das würde ich gerne wäre das ist was das
für einer ist aber da hat man den hand
400 seiten bei sich dabei eigentlich
schon wenn man im feld unterwegs ist das
heißt wenn man irgend einem tümpel steht
oder am strand oder im naturschutzgebiet
dann ist es nicht schlecht wenn man den
dabei hat denn es können immer mal vögel
auftauchen die man nicht im griff hat
die vögel vor der haustür kennt man in
der regel man weiß wie eine amsel aus
sieht man weiß wie eine kohlmeise
aussieht eine blaumeise und so fort aber
wenn die ganzen zugvögel auch wieder
hier sind weil sie hier brüten dann wird
es irgendwann knifflig und da hilft so
ein vogel führer und der führt alle
arten auf und er führt sie zum beispiel
auch nebeneinander auf also das
klassische beispiel ist es gibt zwei
kleine vögel die heißen tipp und
features die gehören beide zur familie
der laub sänger artigen und die sehen
sich unfassbar ähnlich nun hat der der
zilpzalp dunklere beine und der features
hat vielleicht einen deutlicheren über
augen streifen aber das sieht man
eigentlich wenn man im feld steht nicht
so richtig man muss sich dann auf den
gesang verlassen
wenn man aber ein bisschen zeit hat und
der vogel einigermaßen stilles was in
der regel nicht der fall ist aber falls
es mal so ist dann kann man sich anhand
von bestimmten merkmalen zurecht legen
um wen es sich handelt und da ist und
vogelführer wirklich sehr praktisch da
sagt zum beispiel der svensson und dass
der fidesz eine längere hand schwingen
projektion hat als deshalb und da sind
die vögel in exakt derselben position
nebeneinander aufgeführt exakt gleich
ausgeleuchtet und dann gibt es so kleine
so kleine hinweise an dem man sich
orientieren kann da guckt man sich die
zeichnung an und sie teuer die
handschuhe projektion beim fehlt es ist
tatsächlich länger die anfänge
projektion das ist ein fachbegriff aus
der topographie das ist ein fachbegriff
aus der topographie von vögeln und sie
bemisst den teil der flüge spitze der
wenn der vogel den den flügel angelegt
hat über die längste schirm feder
hinausragt und die schiitisch ihren
fehlern wiederum sind die inneren drei
bis fünf arme schwingen eines flügels
und die arme schwingen wiederum sind die
großen federn die letztlich so etwas wie
die tragfläche bilden und das hat man
relativ schnell raus das klingt jetzt
wahnsinnig kompliziert aber wenn man
so ein buch immer wieder rein guckt dann
versteht man das sehr schnell sehr gut
und das ist übrigens auch eine wichtige
sache
man sollte sich in so einem
bestimmungsbuch nicht nur die bilder
angucken die häufig ganz toll sind also
einfach unglaublich tolle illustration
sondern man muss den text auch wirklich
lesen weil erst wenn man den text liest
kommt man wirklich nah an den vogel ran
also auch ein klassisches beispiel man
steht im winter an einem see und der
jagd ein greifvogel den man immerhin als
falken identifiziert hat und dann gibt
man sich auf die suche und dann könnte
man der idee verfallen dass es sich um
einen baum falken handelt aber wenn man
dann den text in bestimmungsbuch liest
wird man erfahren dass bei uns falken im
winter im südlichen afrika sind das aber
wanderfalken gerne im winter an
gewässern jagen
und so kommt man kommt man am ende dahin
und im idealfall hat man den vogel dann
verlässt also ohne dein zwanziger nicht
das haus never ever okay was haben die
leute vor 1999 gemacht da hat es gab
andere vogelführer es gibt es gibt sehr
viele bestimmungsbücher die gibt es auch
heute noch schon ältere es gibt auch
immer wieder neue früher gab es häufig
vogelführer die sehr ungenau waren da
waren die zeichnungen nicht so gut oder
da waren die die fotos sehr schlecht
weil der vogel schlecht ausgeleuchtet
war weil er nur in einem kleid zu sehen
war und das war dann sehr runter gerockt
so ein vogel wechselt ja das kleid
männchen sehen häufig anders aus als
weibchen es gibt das so genannte pracht
kleid das legt ein vogel in der brutzeit
an es gibt es sogenannte schlicht kleid
das legt er außerhalb der brutzeit an
und wenn man zu wenig abbildung von so
einem vogel hat und das war lange zeit
der fall in vielen nicht so guten
bestimmungsbüchern dann kann es
passieren dass man einen vogel bestimmt
oder halt auch gar nicht und es gibt so
es gibt so notorisch schwieriger arten
wie wie greifvögel möwen und leni kohlen
league holen das sind diese verhandlung
beinen und langen schnabel die die im
meer so rum stochern mit ihrem schnabel
die zu bestimmen ist tricky und da
braucht man wirklich abbildung oder
fotos also illustration oder fotos in
allen kleidern und das leistet dieser
svensson und andere bücher haben das in
dieser form nicht gemacht ich bin ein
bisschen überrascht zu hören dass die
zeichnung da den vorzug hat bekommt vor
dem foto ja das ist eigentlich noch eine
idee aus der zeit als es noch keine so
guten fotos gab es ist ein bisschen
geschmackssache
illustration haben den vorteil dass man
auf sehr engem raum direkt zur
vergleiche anstellen kann also wie
gerade gesagt selbst verso s direkt
nebeneinander in exakt derselben pose
vor neutralem hintergrund also bei dem
einen ist nicht erlaubt und bei dem
anderen ist irgendwie blauer himmel in
exakt derselben körperhaltung und dass
man gewisse merkmale hervorheben kann
beziehungsweise sie in einem
idealzustand zeigen kann und das ist
natürlich da würden jetzt foto
befürworter sagen so begegnet man einem
vogel niemals in freier wildbahn aber um
etwas über seinen über seine haltung
über sein gefieder zu lernen ist das
wirklich von vorteil
ich habe auf einem ohr habe nie auf
einem foto gesehen dass das rotkehlchen
das ist der lieblingsvogel der deutschen
ist auch der vogel des jahres geworden
dass das rot kirchen eine kleine sehr
schmale gelbe flügel binde hat es mir
nie aufgefallen
bis sich das im svensson gelesen habe
und dann habe ich mal darauf geachtet
draußen und dann festgestellt dass
stimmt aber man vieles sieht man gar
nicht obwohl man den vogel schon so oft
vor sich hatte und da ist so ein buch
mit demonstrationen echter vorteil
bist du gleich 99 auf den fans
angekommen oder wie war das
erstkontakt mit diesem leder kam später
der der kam später und dann kam auch
wirklich als als die app kam kam als
sofort die app weil die koste zwar geld
aber die hat vogelstimmen die man sich
anhören kann
und das ist wirklich ein echter vorteil
wenn manche arten also wie gesagt für
das selbstbestimmte man am besten anhand
der stimme oder wald baumläufer garten
baumläufer das sind so art und die
funktionieren so auf lange sicht auf ein
fernglas hat funktioniert nicht so super
und da ist nicht auf und dieses buch
also
99 bis 2007 als smartphone rauskam ist
ja noch ein salon schritt sind ja noch
mal acht jahre in denen du
wahrscheinlich schon mit diesem buch
gearbeitet hast hatte sich sofort
überzeugt hast du dann deine
ornithologischen bücherschrank
ausgemistet und ganz viel platz gehabt
auf einmal weil die anderen ja den
kürzeren gezogen haben
also erst mal überfordert sein weil es
viele abbildungen hatte viel genauer ist
als alle anderen
man fängt also dort er einmal zu suchen
hat aber die systematik des buchs
relativ schnell im griff und generell
gilt wenn man also wenn man wirklich
ernst macht mit der vogelbeobachtung
dann sollte man nicht nur ein
bestimmungsbuch mit sich rumschleppen
sondern mehrere alter ja tatsächlich am
besten eins mit illustrationen und eins
mit fotos das ist so der idealfall macht
kaum jemand aber also ich nehme halt
denen immer und mittlerweile hat auch
einen handy ja also mein buch ist auch
dass das was ich hier noch ob das ist
schon sehr runter gewohnt sieht gerade
vor mir und es zerfällt klingt als
hättest du es wirklich die ganze zeit
dabei jetzt kommt die urlaubszeit
deshalb das thema sommer bücher und ein
rad von dir vogel beobachten im urlaub
sollte man das immer machen sollte man
das kann man das nur nebenbei machen
kann man das mal so einen halben tag
machen ist es schon vogel beobachten für
dich wenn man irgendwo im schatten oder
in der sonne oder was liegt und dann was
sieht und hört was man noch nie gesehen
und gehört hat ja oder auch was man
schon oft gesehen und gehört hat also
ein gutes beispiel ist der buchfink das
mit der amsel unser häufigster brutvogel
der singt häufig so kleine dialekte in
südeuropa sind da noch mal ganz anders
als hier
aber auch hier also wenn ich jetzt im
park bin und ich höre den buchfink a und
b die klingen nicht genau ich und das
ist schon ganz interessant also man kann
auch wenn man morgens wach wird und
schon mal raus hört und man hört die
ersten ringeltauben oder die amsel oder
ganz frühen hausrotschwanz dann ist das
ja schon eine form von vogel beobachtung
es gibt so ein buch das heißt
birdwatching da geht's halt wirklich
darum über den sound sie
den vogel zu nähern und man kann es
überall machen man muss gar nicht urlaub
haben also es geht natürlich auch in der
stadt auf dem weg zur arbeit und an
jedem vögel gibt es ja über alles geht
an jedem ort und man kommt gar nicht
umhin werde ich dich richtig verstehe
also ich nicht andere wahrscheinlich
schon aber bei mir ist ein gewisser
zwang schon dabei
ja klingt aber nicht nach einem
unglücklichen 2 ist tatsächlich tolles
hobby kann ich nur empfehlen alles klar
liebe hörer kauft euch ein fernglas und
bestimmungsbuch und bitte bitte
also in diesem sommer würde ich als
großes sommer buch was ich jedem
empfehlen kann mitzunehmen empfehlen sei
dies mit ihre ersten erzählungen die sie
veröffentlicht hat unter dem titel grand
july and sandra kegel kennen sie
ebenfalls aus unserem bücher podcast sie
ist redaktionsleiterin im förderung und
war und literatur redakteuren bei uns im
haus erzählt uns mehr über das buch
liebe sandra das besondere ist dass wir
sehr es müssen natürlich als große roman
autorin kennen ihren die befehle zeigen
von der schönheit und sie ist immer um
erzählungen herum gewandert und hat sich
darauf einlassen wollen obwohl sie viele
essays politische essays
kulturhistorische essays geschrieben hat
die die sie auch in buchform
veröffentlicht hat aber jetzt zum ersten
mal literarische kurze stücke und sie
ist eine hinreißende erzählerin also sie
kann mit diesem prinzip ganz viel
anfangen
das besondere an diesem erzählungsband
der texte versammelt aus den letzten
zehn 15 jahren ist dass sie so
unterschiedlich sind also da gibt es
auto fiktionen da gibt es disco pi da
gibt es science fiction
gesellschaftssatire parabel eine
geschichte ist aus der sicht gottes
erzählt manche sind klassisch gehalten
die also an anschoss doris wie zb von
george sanders erinnern und andere sind
völlig verrückt völlig literarisch bis
an die grenzen gehen und das ist das
schöne und das abwechslungsreiche und
man kann eine geschichte lesen dann kann
das buch zu schlagen sich anderen
zuwenden und dann kann man am nächsten
tag die nächste geschichte lesen
wir kämpfen in den einzelnen geschichten
die sei dies müsse die man aus den
romanen kennt oder ist es ein buch
voller überraschungen
es hat viel von ihren romanen was die
thematik angeht also selbst beschäftigt
sich ja eigentlich immer als beobachter
in unserer gegenwart mit der frage
wie sich das verhältnis von herkunft und
identität
was es damit auf sich hat ja also wie
man wurde der mann ist welche million
mann entstand oder welchem viertel oder
welcher stadt
und das ist etwas das die protagonisten
ihrer kurzgeschichten eben auch vielfach
umtreibt sind geschichten die
überwiegend in amerika spielen es ist ja
geboren in wilson einem arbeiterviertel
in london und lebt heute in new york und
unterrichtet glaube ich auch an der
andrew kreatives schreiben oder kreativ
writing und die ihre figuren sind
künstler angestellte junge leute die
darum kämpfen damit dringend tatsächlich
woher sie kommen wer sie sind was sie
was sie für familiäre verstrickungen
haben wie sie da raus kommen
manche sind so komponiert wie ein
musikstück also das ist total richtig zu
reale stücke manches sind auch themen
wie mutterschaft etwas das es muss ja
selber eben auch aus eigenem erleben
kennt da gibt es eine ganz berührende
szene zwischen einer tochter und einer
mutter die sich eben über das was mutter
und tochter seinen ausmacht unterhalten
also große literarische erzählkunst
ein wort noch zu dem gewicht dieses
buches also löschung gewicht ist das ist
das
tief und leicht oder ist es tief und
schwer
das buch ist es einst in dem man aus dem
man leicht wieder auftaucht aus den
einzelnen geschichten das ist ja so ein
thema bei kurzgeschichten das ja auch
immer so doch ein ganzes stück weit über
sich selbst hinaus weisen und man sie
dann doch nicht so schnell los wird
einfach buch zuklappen ist ja nicht so
getan wie man dann einen roman zu klappt
werner gelesen ist wie fährt es sich
damit also es ist vor allem überwiegend
wahnsinnig humorvoll der weiß dass man
spielt ja immer eine große rolle
und selbst wenn sie eine geschichte hat
über einen künstler der eben darum ringt
wie kann man in diesen politisch thronen
die zeiten überhaupt noch kunst machen
sind eigentlich zwei künstler die sich
darüber auseinandersetzen ist das vor
allem komisch aber das ist geradezu eine
karikatur eines österreichischen malers
der dann nach new york kommt und wie er
das ganze amerika wahrnimmt das ist vor
allem komisch das heißt ich würde sagen
diese diese geschichten haben ganz
ernste ganz große teams sind aber
unheimlich leicht selbstreferenziell und
oftmals üben lustig erzählt obwohl es
eben eine sehr gewissenhaft autoren ist
sehr genau weiß was sie tut aber sie
erlaubt ist sich als oktober in diesen
kurzgeschichten tatsächlich diese form
wie ich schon erwähnte so weit zu
treiben dass es bisweilen fast
skizzenhaft daher kommt also unfertig
also es ist hat fast das fragment haftet
und das macht es eben auch so leicht
zugänglich
wie hast du das buch entdeckt wann ein
erstes mal gelesen ich habe es entdeckt
weil ich eigentlich alles lese was von
sadismus auf meinen tisch kommt das ist
eine der autorinnen
die ich immer lese das ist jetzt eine
neue erscheinungsform paar wochen
erschienen und das irgendwie klar dass
ich das lesen würde und das ist aber ein
buch das ich auch immer wieder immer
wieder hervor ziehen würde uns noch mal
zu lesen oder um darin zu lesen das ist
ja das schöne an büchern mit
kurzgeschichten man kann sie häufiger
als eine
mal wieder zur hand nehmen weil sie eben
diese vielen zugänge haben und man kann
auf seite 2 150 aufschlagen und ist bei
einem anfang eine tolle empfehlung
vielen dank liebe sondern sehr gern das
sommerloch meiner wahl besteht aus zwei
bänden die damals separat erschienen
sind dh arterien oder die hand oder auf
deutsch die hyperion gesänge von den
singles der erste band heißt papieren
also ich wäre der zweite heißt sofort
aufhören also der zusammenbruch oder in
der deutschen fassung der fall von
materie geht mandat ist filmkritiker
schriftsteller matte fan - gleich plus
my little pony fan geschätzter kollege
bei uns im beton und erzählen mehr von
diesen beiden büchern genau also der
punkt bei diesen beiden büchern ist dass
sie ja ganz weit draußen anfangen das
heißt sie erzählen die geschichte
sozusagen der ultimativen hinter welt
seine situation nämlich ein planet der
weit weit draußen liegt weit weiter
blick von einer galaktischen
zivilisation also eine zukunfts
zivilisation die ganz viele sonnen
sternen planeten monde umfasst aber
diese welt eigentlich nicht das ist so
ein hinterhof ging und diese welt heißt
ferien und auf dieser welt gibt es so
genannte zeit gräber das sind artefakte
bauten archäologische objekte bei denen
messungen von physikern und natürlich
auch physikerinnen nachgewiesen haben
dass die entropie da umgekehrt ist das
heißt dass der hang zu immer größer und
unordnung der in wirklichen
physikalischen systemen existiert da
umgedreht ist das heißt diese dinger
laufen rückwärts durch die zeit die
kommen also sozusagen aus der zukunft
wir können sie aber sehen sie sind
normalerweise verschlossen und das buch
fängt aber damit an dass sie sich jetzt
öffnen und es gibt um diesen planeten
herum eine art religion einen kult von
einer kirche des streik das schweiz ist
ein wesen das weitgehend aus männern
besteht und aus spiesen und das
furchtbaren metallischen sachen ein
grausames etwas mit glühenden kohle
augen und die beten dass an als eine art
teufel und gott in einem und glauben
dass dieses wesen irgendwie die dazu
berufen ist die menschheit zu erlösen
und diese zeit gräber sind heilige
stätten für diese kirche und das heißt
da gibt es bilder farben und das buch
erzählt von den letzten dieser
pilgerfahrten denn da sich die gräber
öffnen geht jetzt die zeit zu ende und
weiß gott was alles passiert und diese
pilgergruppe ist also handverlesen teils
von der kirche teils von der politik da
ist von militärs teils von
verschwörungen und es sind handverlesene
7 sehr sehr interessante figuren und
diese sehr sehr interessanten figuren
erzählen auf der fahrt zu den zeit
gräbern ihre vorgeschichte und es gibt
ein sehr berühmtes buch effekt eines der
ersten bücher der wirklich englischen
literatur die wir so nennen das sind die
canterbury tales von herrn georgi chance
und die sind auch so aufgebaut da gibt
es also weiß nicht in wie kaufmann und
ritter und die erzählen hat so ihre
vorgeschichte und warum sie auf der
pilgerfahrt sind und genauso ist es hier
und der witz ist nun der last also einen
soldaten du hast eine privatdetektivin
du hast ein dichter du hast einen
religionsgelehrten du hast einen fahrer
einen katholischen pfarrer obwohl der
katholizismus eine ganz ganz alte und
zerbröckelte und nicht mehr seiner
zahlreiche sekte ist in dieser zukunft
und die erzählen halt alle warum sie da
hinfahren und es stellt sich raus sie
waren entweder schon mal da war oder ihr
leben hängt damit zusammen und das
eigentlich aller tollste daran ist dass
du dadurch in diesem sommer buch mehrere
bücher hast denn natürlich ist jede
dieser geschichten für sich genommen
super interessant und stilistisch
verschieden von den anderen dh der
katholische priester klingt wie der
tatsächlich existiert haben der
katholische priester tellerwäscher daher
gleichzeitig archäologe und
evolutionstheorie war dh der stil dieses
berühmten katholischen mystischen
schriftstellers und archäologen
tellerwäscher da ist der stil des
kapitels dass der geistliche erzählt
dann hast du die privatdetektive in die
ist so die erzählt dann natürlich im
stil eines hartgesottenen krimis also so
schwarze serie oder so peschl hammett
raymond chandler dann hast du die
dichter der ist ganz wichtig und ein
absoluter auf
ein völlig rücksichtloser mensch der
sein eigenes leben und das manch anderer
personen für sein hauptwerk nämlich die
pass auf hyperion cantus geopfert hat
und jetzt an diesen ort zurückkehrt weil
das zeigt dieses grauenhafte wesen seine
muse ist das glaubt er zumindest und er
will sein gedicht zu ende schreiben und
das ist die letzte gelegenheit und
dessen bekenntnisse und erinnerungen
sind eben im spiel dann natürlich der
hohen literatur geschrieben als es
klingelt irgendwie ezra pound drin durch
und du hast nämlich untertöne von ja von
moderner anspruchsvolle literatur
sozusagen dann hast du soldaten das ist
dann natürlich eine ganz hemingway sg
oder norman mailer haftet affe macht
mathe geschichte ja so halt also das
heißt du kriegst stil eigentümlichkeiten
die sozusagen vertrautes verwandeln denn
man weiß ja ungefähr was katholisch ist
man weiß ungefähr was ein krieg ist man
weiß ungefähr was ein kriminalfall ist
aber berühmt sind ja die leute die den
swans danach macht geworden weil sie es
auf ihre jeweils ganz eigene arzt tun
diese geschichten zu erzählen und mit
dieser art spielt er dann
du hast also vertraute handlungsmuster
stoffe usw die auf ungewöhnliche art
erzählt werden du hast aber auch das
nicht vertraute und das ist natürlich
eine welt in der es so was gibt die zeit
gräber oder diese diese kosmische
zivilisation der hegemonie und so und
das aller wahnsinnig daran ist dass
dieses buch und das heißt ich habe
geschummelt denn es ist wie du jetzt ja
gemerkt haben dürfte ist eigentlich eine
bibliothek und kein buch dass diese
bibliothek im endeffekt am schluss der
handlung und das ist das was mich jedes
mal wieder neu verblüfft und wo ich
jedes mal beim wiederlesen oder wie es
im moment mache vorlesen feststelle an
der stelle ist das schon gelegt diese
spur hat das hat also das ist also
wirklich alles geplant gewesen dass
dieser ganze wahnsinn am ende
tatsächlich einen befriedigenden sehr
andere hörenden mit viel pathos mit
vielen philosophischer schwerer aber
auch mit großer menschlicher wucht
seinen sinn ergibt also man hat
tatsächlich eine runde geschichte wo man
sagt
dieses ende lohnt auch diesen langen weg
den man eben mit diesem siegel leuten da
verbringt und und das ist so man sieht
die dinge frisch man sieht die dinge
neumann sieht sogar dieses buch bei
jedem wieder lesen
und ich weiß nicht ob es rüber kommt
aber ich finde es nicht gut klingt so
klingt so wie ist denn dieses buch in
dein leben gekommen wie hast du's
entdeckt oder wie hattest dich entdeckt
und wann hast du es und unter welchen
umständen das erste mal gelesen ich habe
es glücklicherweise tatsächlich in die
finger gekriegt so ein zeitpunkt wo ich
noch relativ neu war
denn natürlich über allen sachen die in
irgendeinem genre klassiker sind werden
diese bücher ja bald zugedeckt von
sekundärem also von meinungen von fans
von von kritischen äußerungen von auch
ja einfach sekundärliteratur also
irgendwelche überblicks büchern das
waren die wichtigen zeigt sich also und
dann findest du nicht mehr selber zu
ihnen und bei mir war es so ich war
relativ früh science-fiction-fan wir
viel allein die hände durch biografische
zufälle als ich gerade lesen gelernt
hatte also zwischen sieben und zehn und
war dann so ziemlich druck würde ich
sagen bis zu 87 also 16 17 jahre alt und
bin dann umgezogen hatten teil meiner
bibliothek auch verschenkt verkauft ein
neues leben angefangen in einer etwas
größeren stadt würde ich heute sagen
damals dachte ich wow großstadt nämlich
freiburg und habe sozusagen so gedacht
wie man das so denkweise genre
begeisterung ja das war halt so meine
kindheit mit ein bisschen pubertät und
jetzt weiter wachsen und so und hat eine
zeitlang eher so dass gelesen was eben
als yahoo literatur literaturhaus
literatur vom germanistischen seminar
oder vom liste seminar empfohlen die
literatur und sowas war die ganze wird
gerne für mich entdeckt was weiß ich
dass pippa po und so ein bisschen die
finger gelassen von der science fiction
weil ich auch den eindruck irgendwann
gehabt habe den man ja auch bei western
oder krimis haben kann
jetzt kenne ich doch so ziemlich alles
und zwar nicht jedes konkrete werk aber
so aber jetzt geht es so weiter da habe
ich mir schon gedacht so ist das halt in
dieser art von buch und bin ja so ein
bisschen abspenstig geworden dem und
dann gab es aber in diesem freiburg
ebenso eine buchhandlung wie hieß glaube
ich damals noch nicht vor hieß das
später aber oho das war erst eine
buchhandlung genau hier ist ja am anfang
das war einfach comics und science
fiction und ich glaube sogar ein
bisschen krimi und rollenspiele und das
hat sich das wieder aufgespalten und
mehrere buchhandlungen in freiburg und
einer davon landet irgendwann in berlin
und so also ist auch ein ganz
merkwürdiges einzelner tiere und dass
ich dann gespalten informiert
aber in dem science fiction teil dieser
buchhandlung hat mir das jemand
irgendwann in die hand gegeben weil ich
immer so da in die buchhandlung gehen
fast immer nur comics gekauft hat und
dann aber gesagt habe ja auch früher er
sich habe öfter mal die bewerbung macht
ja früher habe ich viel gelesen und das
sollte aber eigentlich auch heißen
menschen gehabt dass da stehen also ich
ließ das ja nicht mehr
aber dieser fähige buchhändler hat das
halt so verstanden früher habe ich aber
irgendwie mag ich nicht mehr und hat das
so als eine art aufforderung wohl
verstanden das wollen wir doch mal sehen
ob du uns and kommst auf dauer werde es
in die hand gedrückt und ich habe glaube
ich das erste drittel so in der woche
gewesen bis ich dann so gemerkt hatte ok
jetzt fängt das völlig neues an also das
heißt das erste drittel hat die ersten
zwei geschichten von den ersten beiden
pilger gestalten und märkte dann
natürlich mit der zweiten geschichte
oder es ist jetzt noch mal ein ganz
anderes buch so und danach das fahrt auf
weil ich sozusagen begriff okay hier
erwartet nicht eigentlich viel mehr als
ich bleibe dabei der stange über diese
1500 1600 seiten haben und kriegt so
eine person und ihren lebenslauf sondern
ich fix und kaleidoskop und dann nahm
das sofort auf und ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher wenn ich jetzt nicht lockere
der zweite band also folgten mit anderen
worten doch auch noch mal 600 seiten
das kann nicht viel länger gewesen sein
als tatsächlich zwei nächte
also das war auch eine zeit ich hatte
damals keinen keinen festen job das war
so zwischen zwischen schule zivildienst
auf der einen seite und dann uni plus
job und gar nicht einfach so ein
bisschen rum und das heißt man konnte
sich auch leisten sozusagen zu sagen ich
lege es erst dann weg wenn ich jetzt
physisch nicht mehr weiter lesen kann
und es war halt so ein buch das das von
mir wollte und insofern so in der
verkehrten änderung würde ich immer
sagen ich hab das ganze buch drei nächte
gebraucht aber das kann nicht sein und
deswegen würde ich sagen sozusagen eine
woche und dann noch mal zwei nächte aber
eben gleich viele teile also sozusagen
die eine woche für die für den ersten
teil und den rest dann super super
schnell ich weiß halt noch tatsächlich
gehabt so sehr hat die beiden lebens
einschneidenden sachen
sehr sehr präzise erinnerungen an dann
gehst du zum bäcker war jetzt ist es
schon so früh und und also ich weiß noch
eine cola gekauft und somit kosten und
ich weiß die straße noch und dass dafür
eine sparkasse stand und so ich weiß
dass in ganzen morgen noch nach diesem
sehr sehr
wo legen und wehmütigen und eben für
mich doch sehr selektiv einschneidenden
leseerlebnis dieses dieses abschlusses
von dem buch hat sich was verändert
durch das lesen auf der banalsten ebene
habe ich da dann wieder natürlich
angefangen science fiction fan zu sein
und bin es dann auch geblieben
und ansonsten hatte sich verändert dass
ich dass diese trennung ein bisschen
verschwunden war von es gibt
künstlerisch anspruchsvolle komplizierte
literatur und es geht generatoren die
dich einfach packt schüttelt ausbringt
von ihnen nach außen krempelt und dann
wieder hingestellt und du bist irgendwie
emotional mitgenommen hast dein ganzes
leben angefangen neu zu bewerten und und
hast einen anderen begriff von
freundschaft oder liebe oder so oder
hast den begriff den du schon immer hat
hat es jetzt so klar serviert gekriegt
in der geschichte dass du sie sozusagen
mit deswegen mit bildern verbinden
kannst das vorher nicht gehen oder so
oder kann es dann sagen ja sowie der mit
dem befreundet ist mensch das hatte ich
doch auch mal das war an dieser mensch
und so also was wir halt von büchern
wollen so ein spiegel von unserem leben
der dinge klarer macht und ich habe es
wie gesagt seid ja mehrfach neu gelesen
wie es gerade jemanden vor was dann so
wahrscheinlich jetzt ein jahr gehen wird
wobei sich auch das tier also wieder der
beschleunigungs effekt einstellt also
die person der ich vorlese sagt dir zu
ja aber heute bitte noch eins oder so
oder was erst wieder am freitag wollen
wir uns nicht treffen oder so und ja das
ist das hat so ein speed dieses buches
hat seine das hat so einen gradienten
hinten drin und ich würde es so sagen
also natürlich nutzt sich diese wo gott
hoffentlich passiert ihnen nichts oder
man ist diese liebesgeschichte schön
dann irgendwann ab weil man ja weiß wie
es weitergeht
aber ich staune immer noch über die enge
verbindung von formaler kühnheit von von
stilistischen können
und emotionalem wert also es ist nie ich
kann ganz schnell gitarre spielen
sondern ich kann ganz schnell gitarre
spielen aber die melodie so es ist hat
es hat so dieses gleichgewicht von von
von können und wollen und meinen und und
fühlen und so das ist wirklich ist
erstaunlich also es gibt es gibt
inzwischen bücher die mir emotional
sondern auch mehr bedeuten es gibt
bücher die ich für technisch geschickter
halte dann gibt es bücher die ich für
anspruchsvolle papa papa blablabla aber
wenn man das überhaupt könnte ein
durchschnitt bilden aus können und herz
oder so dann gibt es da immer noch keins
was was so viele andere bücher ersetzen
kann einfach nur durch die durch dieses
viel was ist hat was aber ein
qualitatives viel ist was keine blöde
menge oder so viele verschieden oder so
klingt für mich nach dem buch zum
verkrümeln also ja so übergangszeit oder
es ist nass und kalt und unangenehm
draußen und man hat so seine leseecke
sein sonst was zum lesen wo immer du
liest keine ahnung aber noch nicht nach
irgendwas von sommer was für mich auch
immer heisst ich lese wo ich sonst nicht
lese ich bin ich bin wo ich sonst nicht
bin
wir haben uns so und draußen ich wollte
dass ich würde das umdrehen
ich weiß dass eben dieser nachmittag vor
dem ersten mord war im seepark der
seepark ist einfach so ein ding das
haben sie für die bundesgartenschau
gemacht und war dann ein geschenk an die
menschheit das immer noch bestand hat
das ist so naherholungs dingsbums halt
und da ist es ein notorisch hammer laut
und vor allen dingen ist es so dass der
spot ist trifft man da natürlich
sämtliche leute die man kennt noch mal
so richtig
und da lag ich aber und ich weiß auch ja
da geht es glaube ich an dem tag gesehen
und die kinder waren noch lauter als
sonst und so aber das ding hat als so
eine kraft das auch wenn du es in
häppchen liest sozusagen also ich würde
mir zu tragen dass auch in der rollstuhl
disco mit epileptischen blitzlichtern
noch weiter lesen zu wollen so
das klingt nach einer wirklichen
empfehlung nicht für die rollstuhl disco
war für dieses buch
dann geht man ja gerne also vielleicht
noch eine anekdote wenn diese brauchen
kannst natürlich habe ich das buch viel
stehen sehen bei leuten die viele bücher
haben weil es ja ein buch ist das aus
vielen büchern zusammengesetzt ist und
also leute so genannten leseratten
natürlich besonders gut gefällt
aber mein mann mein größter ein lächeln
moment mit dem buch war dass ich mal auf
einer lesetour mit den zwei holländern
von der agentur bildet in verschiedenen
studenten guten einquartiert wurde und
dann in einer wurde landete von seinem
dj der nur zwei bücher besaß und das
achte buch war irgendwas mit drogen das
will ich jetzt nicht kommentieren und
dieses ding so das heißt anscheinend ist
es auch eine klammer um leute die ganz
viel lesen und leute die vielleicht
nicht ganz viel aber wahrscheinlich ganz
intensiv lesen hoffentlich machen sie
keine filme und keine fernsehserie draus
denn das wird natürlich seit jahren
immer wieder angedacht weil es halt die
leute die es lieben so sehr lieben und
dann sagen natürlich irgendwie
produzenten ja aber dann müsste man
damit auch geld machen und so ich möchte
in diesem einen einzigen fall
tatsächlich das was so viele leute sagen
die sagen nein das sind nicht mal dass
ich meine figuren wie ich sie mir
vorstelle und so ich will keine von
jemand anders gemachten bilder dazu
haben sie mich und dann werde ich
natürlich euphorisch besprechen wenn es
kommen so abgemacht
in den schoß sondern auf unserer seite
www.faz.net bücher - podcast bücher mit
finden sie ein paar artikel zu den
büchern und überhaupt sommer büchern und
was thomas kumbrink in der frankfurter
anthologie aus dem so kurzen wir
ergreifenden gedicht einfache sätze von
helmut heißenbüttel herausliest dass sie
liebe hörerinnen und hörer gleich im
anschluss vorgelesen bekommen wie immer
von thomas huber wenn sie uns schreiben
möchten immer gern die e mailadresse ist
bücher - podcast faz.de bücher mit wenn
sie uns abonnieren wollen mit sternchen
oder sonstwie bewerten oder licon oder
teilen sie finden schon gelegenheit dazu
in den pott ketzern oder in den sozialen
medien zum beispiel bei instagram wo wir
als faz bücher mit unterwegs sind vielen
dank auch diesmal fürs zuhören alles
gute und auf bald helmut heißenbüttel
einfache sätze während ich stehe fällt
der schatten hin morgensonne entwirft
die erste zeichnung blühen ist ein
tödliches geschäft
ich habe mich einverstanden erklärt ich
liebe
[Musik]
[Applaus]